[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Jay warshaw we're here
for you this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five we are fresh off of the
airplane uh from an amazing Building
Wealth live in Austin Texas last night
uh myself Jade Dr John deloney and Dave
Ramsey at a packed house Jake and it was
uh it was really fun it was fun
got off that plane
she has a daisy kid well I had I had a
20-minute session in the cryo freezer
and so uh I don't even know what that is
just made that up that's not a thing
don't listen anything I'm saying but we
had a great time on the road and uh
we'll talk more in the show about the
remaining dates so let's get to it
people are lined up ready to go it's a
free phone call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five I also want to
point out we have a fantastic studio
audience watching out there they're very
excited to be here and we love having
them with us let's go to Roanoke
Virginia Megan is there Megan how can we
help
hi guys thank you uh so much for taking
my call
um absolutely I think uh my husband and
I are in baby step two and we want to
know if it's okay to pause the baby
steps to uh cash flow a vehicle I drive
about 6 000 miles every two weeks wow
and yeah and I had uh I had gotten
written so sorry I get very nervous and
I stutter that's all right you're doing
great take your time um okay
um I had gotten rid of we had a
15 000. that we've paid off 40 cents um
I'm sorry towards the end of last year
so we've really been booking it but part
of that was we got rid of a car payment
in a car we had saved up cash to buy a
cheap four thousand dollar car and
um it just completely broke down last
night and it'll probably be two to three
at a minimum to fix it and I know Dave
says don't just buy a new car when it
breaks
um but I'm wondering if my situation is
any different where I can just you know
pause the baby steps save up and buy
something just a tad bit newer so that
way I have something reliable for my
work
why are you um what's causing you to
drive the that many miles I'm just
curious that's a lot
um I it is so much I'm working 70 to 90
hours a week right now I'm dying um but
I'm a medical Courier so um hospitals
doctors offices that kind of thing I
have to pick it up and then drive it you
know whatever the radius is the lab okay
okay
um how much you have saved so far that
you could put towards this vehicle
um right now we just have the emergency
fund
um and because everything else we were
you know throwing towards the debt so
the the car that's broken down you said
you paid four thousand for it
yes ma'am and it's going to cost two to
three thousand to fix
yes ma'am have you so much I'm sorry how
much is in the emergency fund a thousand
just a thousand yeah just a thousand
okay yeah because we're only in baby
step two right all right have you
shopped it around to a couple of
different places or is this just one
guy's opinion
this is well uh myself and my family
were all pretty mechanically inclined um
and so from the research I've done it's
an inverter where it's a hybrid vehicle
because I need a good fuel economy for
all the miles I drive you know save
money and
um from what I can find the cheapest on
the web for parts and labor is going to
be two to three if I take it to a
dealership and have to have someone work
on it it's probably going to be much
more because you know they have to
charge for the labor
um
you know if if it's me
and this has you know you just got the
car it's not like it's proven to be a a
money hole or a money pit I'd probably
go ahead and get it fixed and if it
seems like it's going to continue to
give you problems then I'd consider
getting out but I mean I would I would
try to get this done dirt cheap I mean
there's been times that Sam and I have
ordered the part ourself on Amazon and
then taken it and it has saved us
hundreds instead of having the dealer
order or the mechanic order it so
whatever you can do to kind of get
crafty and try to save money and cut
costs
um don't spend more than two thousand to
get this fixed and if you start seeing
that this is a trend and that this you
just kind of got sold a lemon then get
out of it but um yeah Stack Up try to
stack up in cash flow this if you can so
that you don't have to start from
scratch with your your emergency fund do
you think you could do that
yeah yeah I could probably do it in
about a week or two it's just
um whether or not it's worth it or I
should just put it towards a new one
what do you think Ken well I want to
know what you're going to do while the
car is being fixed or while we're
waiting to get the car fixed what's your
solution because you didn't you're not
going to stop working right
no I'm not I'm actually
um they went out last night and this
morning I'm already in a rental so I'm
cash flowing the rental until it's
either fixed or I find a new one
depending on what you guys want me to do
okay and then the other question I have
is why are you working 70 and I don't I
don't begrudge this I'm just curious why
are you working 70 to 90 hours a week
um because uh my husband and I Oh I
thought I wouldn't get emotional but
for the six years of our marriage and we
have a four-year-old and you know we
want to you know go through the steps
and build a better future for him so you
know my husband uh he's he's working a
ton uh he switched to a new job where
he's working a ton and now I'm working a
ton just trying to get this debt out of
our Lives
possible I I just wanted to know what
was going on there and I just want to
encourage you that you all are doing the
right thing and it seems really really
hard right now and what really sucks is
that here you are busting it and all of
a sudden
something bad happens and it can really
discourage you uh but this is life and
you will overcome it uh Jade your story
super intense you know and you've had to
overcome things like this and and so I
throw it back to you to just encourage
your heart right now because I think
that's more important yeah hey don't
grow weary in well doing don't grow
weary in doing what is right because at
the right time all right in just another
year and just a couple of months for you
in just two weeks and at just the right
time you will reap a harvest if you
don't faint
that's what God's word says and and your
you guys are up against it I mean you
guys are moving you're shaking you're
doing it you're sacrificing you're doing
all the right things and that sacrifice
it's tough at the time it is not easy
anybody who's listening to this call
right now what she is going through what
she is sacrificing to win it is not easy
but it is so necessary and the reward
will be so worth it for those who do not
faint so not just for you but anybody
listening keep going Megan keep going
whoever's listening Janet Paul Tim John
whoever is listening keep going you will
reap a harvest if you do not faint
Isaiah says it will those who wait on
the Lord in the word wait there in that
scripture means hope in the Lord shall
renew their strength they shall Mount up
on wings like eagles and soar they shall
run and not grow weary they shall walk
and not faint and here's the key right
now Megan you are in a season where
you're not even walking you feel like
you're just shuffling and I'm just
telling you that scripture says if if
you're in a season where it's just
really hard and you're just dragging one
foot and then dragging the next foot
you're just shuffling you're not even
walking he says you will not faint and
uh you've got a process that works more
importantly you and your husband have
passion to get to the other side this is
just a temporary impediment you're gonna
blow through it and you're gonna be in
Financial Peace before you know it
living like no one else we're here for
you through the entire Journey she's
Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman don't move
more of the Ramsey show coming up
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
the Ramsey Show continues from our
Nashville area-based headquarters I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joining me in
studio this hour we're here for you to
talk about your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
all three of those areas are so vitally
important that you are winning that
you're healthy in those areas because if
you're not in any one of those areas I
promise you they affect the others the
phone number to jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jade is
our money expert and I'm the work expert
at least that's what they tell me I
don't even like the word expert but
there you go here to help you get
unstuck if you got some of those calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five now let's talk about work and money
combining here great story in my hands
uh this is a fox business article and uh
that's the sound effect is real it's
just the paper uh we like to call it the
paper crinkling on the Ken Coleman show
it's very popular I'm not sure if the
audio guys liked it very much but it's
too late so Jay this is is the story and
this is really cool I'm gonna read the
headline and give you the give you the
uh the guts of it but for those of you
right now that are watching and
listening
and you got this
check I like to call it
in your spirit and it just keeps kind of
popping back up I I should do this or I
could do this or I want to do it but
then you just for whatever reason your
head voice because to drown out your
heart voice
this story is for you
Stephanie bags uh was was named to the
Forbes 30 under 30 list in North America
2023 for her accomplishments who is
Stephanie
well she was a nurse is a nurse by
training
and she turned a side gig into an online
Empire
this is a direct quote from her she told
Fox Business I got started selling my
notes when I graduated from nursing
school I've studied for the board's exam
and it was right when the pandemic
happened so I had nobody to study with
this is my favorite part of the story
Jade I would teach myself to the wall
and I would record it and then I posted
that onto social media and people loved
it they then asked to buy my study
sheets so I created a shop that
eventually became viral and so now I
sell study
sheets
I passed the boards a long time ago but
now I sell them for students who are
approaching the board's exam and taking
tests in nursing school so where that's
how it started so I want you to catch
this for a second Jade here she is and
she doesn't have anybody to study with
so she thinks you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna read my study notes to a wall
essentially and put my cell phone in
front of me and record it and then she
has a hunch or that check and she says
you know what maybe I'll post it on
social what the heck maybe it'll help
one or two nurses that she didn't say
this in the article but we know that to
be true she didn't have a grand plan no
and she says that and so then it picks
up steam and now where is it oh my gosh
she started selling her notes in June of
2020. listen to all you folks out there
who need a little hope
and now she's surpassed two million
dollars in profits last year alone that
was 2022. wow what a story
um she now sells specific uh sheets for
two bucks class specific sheets for 30
or 40 or a giant bundle
for 150 so again this isn't a big
manufactured product she didn't have to
travel overseas to come up with
something fancy Jade she just simply
took something that helped herself and
she shared it and boom what do you think
when you hear a story like that I think
that
we each person has something to offer
boom love that they have something to
offer that can help other people that's
my first thought and then I think about
whatever it is that you're struggling
through yeah whether it's paying off
debt trying to pass your nursing exam
trying to you know whatever it is it's
never just for you yeah there's always
something Beyond you where others can
benefit from that if you choose to look
for it and find it and so that's thing
two now there's a third thing oh it's
coming to you the third thing is all the
time people are trying to make more
money I'm side hustling and people are
quick to go to things that are
pre-existing I'm going to do doordash
I'm going to do ubereats I'm going to do
these other things but I always like to
challenge people there's probably
something that you're already doing yes
that's very it's either your skill set
are very closely related to your skill
set that you could do and make more
money and probably get more joy out of
yeah because you already love doing it
you already know how to do it you
already enjoy doing it and so when it
comes to side hustling because this is
how this started for her it was a side
hustle and then it just grew and grew
and grew
I think that's where you need to start
yeah with the things you already know
you're gonna make more money per hour
because you get to set the hours you get
to set the what you earn and here's the
big uh takeaway
she solved a problem for herself
and then she went
I wonder
if this solution that I created for me
would help anybody else it's a fabulous
question and don't lose the simplest the
Simplicity excuse me of what's going on
here the simple solution for herself
she shared it now that's the takeaway
she shared her study sheets
and she netted two million dollars in
profit last year that's all she did she
took a solution that she created or as
Jade was saying it could be a solution
that she provided for someone else and
all she did was say I'm going to share
it and I I just I just feel like I feel
like there's somebody listening watching
right now that you need to hear this
you're afraid to share it
and I don't know why imposter syndrome
but it doesn't matter you just need to
share it because two people may buy it
or you may make two million dollars next
year but you'll never know so that is
the moral of the story I love love love
love uh Stephanie's story so hopefully
that encourages some people today but
you said it
said at the share and that imposter
syndrome is real
that's a real thing that people face
I'll tell you it's just good
old-fashioned doubt because here's what
I want to say about that number one you
aren't an imposter you aren't and and
that means fraud uh and you don't have a
disease you just have good old-fashioned
doubt I like it Ken I mean I get the
phrase no but what you're saying is
exactly right you don't have a syndrome
welcome to the human race by the way by
the way I I know I'm serious here's what
I want to say hop on in the weather's
fine yeah it's fine here's what I want
to say Jay do you know when you are
experiencing fear
and when you are experiencing doubt
that's a good sign oh yeah I want to
encourage people that are right now you
feel gripped by fear and doubt I want to
encourage you to say this
it's because you are thinking about
moving forward or you're in the act of
moving forward let me tell you people
who never experience fear and doubt
the people who sit on the bleachers of
life and watch everybody else
you can't be afraid of anything when
your elbow deep in popcorn
can't be awful when you're feeding your
face with nachos watching everybody else
come on live life come on so I just want
to encourage people if if you have got
some fear today and some doubt today
it's a good sign that your heart is
engaged in longing for a better future
and so from that standpoint can I just
say don't feel bad about yourself
because you're fearful and doubtful you
should go all right Ken says that that's
a good sign oh yeah that's the sign
you're exiting the comfort zone that's
right and that's a good thing because
you can only stay in the comfort zone so
long you're not going to grow after a
while you know you gotta you gotta shake
it up spice it up I tell you comfortable
is the is the plank in the bridge right
before miserable because because the
longer that I'm comfortable the closer
I'm becoming to Miserable Now I want to
unpack that for a second come on sorry
you're preaching to it you're preaching
right now I know I may take an offering
here later so uh don't be offended if
that just pops out no here's what I want
to say about that
the longer that I'm comfortable the
closer I am to being miserable simply
means this when I'm not being challenged
when I'm not growing
then I am slowly dying and when we say
that you hear people say that what that
really means Jade is is that my soul my
spirit moves
into a languishing where I'm languishing
and that's just I know that's a big word
look it up if you haven't ever heard it
or used it before but it really is this
this it's this kind of No Man's Land of
I'm not growing
and I haven't started going backwards
yet but then what happens is it takes us
to this emotional state where a lot of
depression lives and then anxiety builds
in this place because I'm not growing I
don't see an opportunity to go forward
I've heard it said the enemy of growth
and greatness is just fine that's it
comfortability just fine you ask
somebody how you're doing I'm just fine
yeah you better be you better be careful
and the takeaway from all that is is we
would rather be miserable than
uncomfortable because Misery we know
what we're dealing with when we're
uncomfortable that means we're in a
place of stepping out into the future so
all right we're just getting started the
phone number is ready to roll triple
eight eight two five five two two five
she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman
you're listening to the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw my colleague
joins me this hour we're taking your
calls on your life money questions work
questions you're in a toxic environment
got a boss that's just pathetically bad
you don't know what to do you're scared
to move what have what are the financial
ramifications those work money questions
fun stuff for Jade and I to get into
today triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
the Big Apple Brian is there New York
City Brian how can we help
hi guys how you doing we're having a
blast what's up
so I have a question
um I'm not sure what to do my gut tells
me to do one thing I want to pay off my
mortgage
I have no other debt
uh yo 164 000 on the mortgage
and the home is worth roughly 750.
wonderful
um basically I want to hit the reset
button
um I don't want to have to worry about
the monthly payment anymore uh-huh
so but everyone's telling me no keep
cash in the uh keep the cash in the bank
is this your what is this your how much
you have enough cash to pay it off
completely and after you did that would
you still have three to six months of
expenses saved it would be close so cash
cash I have about 120 000 in cash okay
um my brokerage account you know my um
my personal account is about fifty five
thousand okay that's a taxable brokerage
that's a taxable one and then and
annuities and 401K there's roughly 550
000. what's in the annuities versus the
401K
uh the annuity is about two hundred
thousand
okay so we wouldn't have to touch all of
that I would probably just get I
wouldn't touch the anything in the 401K
I would go for the 120 in cash and I
would look at the 55k that you've got in
the taxable brokerage
um but why why sell the house
he's not selling it he wants to pay it
off no I don't want to sell the house oh
I missed it you want to pay it off yeah
okay um I don't want to have to worry
about the monthly payments anymore my
job I'm not too comfortable with my job
security
um so my mindset is if I don't have a
mortgage payment it's a lot easier just
to pay the taxes
yeah well you know they make sense what
you're saying makes a lot of sense let's
talk about it through the lens of the
baby steps so have you been
um walking our baby steps or is just did
you just kind of end up here you found
us and it's like hey I kind of did that
stuff can you tell me a little bit about
that
um I actually I did we're in the middle
of um FPU now okay great
um
I've had this mindset for a long time
okay everybody kept telling me Oh it's
free money in a two and a half percent
interest rate it's free money why pay it
off why pay it off no okay my mindset is
it's a payment yeah you're right you're
right your instincts are totally right
uh Brian and I'll take it one step
further I would pay off the mortgage as
long as you're continuing to invest 15
into your retirement that's baby step
four baby step five is your saving for
kids college do you have kids I am okay
you're doing that now you're baby step
six which is you can pay off the house
now here's the deal you don't have to go
at a speed of intensity we talk about
the final baby steps being more about
intentionality so you don't have to
liquidate at all and and do that if you
wanted to you could you've got enough
money said I mean you've got the cash
here you've got a taxable brokerage that
for all intents and purposes is really
just a glorified savings account that
you're using it for so I would touch
only those Monies to make it happen I
would not dip into a 401k I would not
dip into any type of retirement if you
had some sort of single stocks or crypto
or something that you were trying to get
out from under you could sell that and
throw it towards your mortgage I'm not
mad at that but I don't want you to feel
like you you're how that you're on fire
and that you're running to put it out
are you paying any on it now above and
beyond just the payment itself the
mortgage payment are you putting in a
little extra now
oh I put a lot how much extra are you
putting above and beyond the payment
itself
um
well my minimum payment I'm doing at
least two and a half times my minimum
payment okay great so here's why I'm
asking this if you didn't take any of
this 120 that you got in cash and put it
towards the 164 balance okay how long
would it take you to pay the house off
with just the extra that you're putting
on it right now what's your payoff date
if you didn't change anything four years
all right so my job's not going to last
four years how do you know
uh it's just the nature of it it's I
mean everything is going electronic
um
okay well that's fine but we still want
you to we still want you to keep your
emergency fund so whatever the 120 is
minus your three to six months whatever
your comfort level is you could put that
on the house I wouldn't touch any of
those other funds
what I basically want to do is empty out
like I would have to empty out my cache
and my brokerage account yeah bring that
down to literally zero and then reset
from there because now I can make the
payments of you know two and a half
times what my mortgage payment is I can
replenish that pretty quickly yeah well
when you say reset here's Here's the the
the big uh piece of this we do not want
you to sacrifice your three to six
months of emergencies to make this
happen if you do this you need to keep
that emergency fund because if you don't
you're putting a giant Target on your
back okay the way we teach it there's a
reason and an order for the way that we
do these baby steps and it's to keep you
protected and it's to make sure that
you're managing uh all sides of this
thing you know what I mean you got you
got a 360 view on what's going on and if
you get rid of that emergency fund
something's gonna happen it always
happens that way the moment you you uh
bleed that thing dry is when the room
exactly so let's do it right again like
I said nothing's on fire so we don't
have to go to extremes but yeah you got
120 in cash maybe you keep 30 of it
aside and you use the rest of it to put
on your mortgage either way you're going
to pay it off faster than four years two
years is most likely wouldn't you say
that's where I was leading you if you
put a good chunk of the 120 cash but we
have a fully funded emergency fund how
much quicker is that going to allow you
to pay it off my guess is here less than
two years two years Max am I right
yeah probably about there all right well
that's right
um you know because I started late too
as far as like with the kids savings
plans like I'm I'm behind on that so you
know I am trying to play catch up there
um
but brother here's the deal
your job gets eliminated okay if it gets
eliminated you're gonna see that coming
that's not going to be a six weeks
notice so you've got this house even if
you don't have it paid off by that time
that house is giving you tremendous
leverage right we're not saying you have
to sell we don't want you to sell it no
but the point is is you're going to be
okay you've got time you're Vigilant
you're on top of this that's what I'm
saying and can I just add if we know
that there's a job loss yeah in your
future can we can we not plan that
you've already got something else in
your back pocket ready or can you
transition before the inevitable takes
place absolutely
well that's the thing we have to be like
a whole career change that's fine I'm
very
jobs like it's such a small little niche
to what I do yeah okay this is what I
deal with listen Brian this is what I
deal with every day and I'm here to tell
you that you have skill and you have
experience that is transferable
period end of statement you have skill
and you have experience that is
transferable to other Industries other
career paths do you understand what I'm
saying
yes do you believe me
uh I do I I think it's
I think it's harder
um it's
it might be a little hard as it relates
to you having to learn a few other new
things or get some certification or put
yourself out there
but you you are acting like you are
pigeonholed and you're acting like a guy
who is trying to batten down the hatches
for the world's greatest storm and I'm
here to tell you
it's not that big of a storm and Brian I
get it so here I'm gonna I'm gonna help
you okay I'm gonna give you two
resources so that you can tackle this
pivot because that's all this is is a
professional pivot I'm going to give you
my get clear career assessment it's a 15
18 minute assessment that's going to
help you be so much more self-aware of
what you good at doing what you love to
do and what motivates you and then I'm
going to give you the book that's the
companion to it think of the the
assessment as a compass and then the
book from paycheck to purpose is the
guide up the new Mountain hang on the
line we're going to give you those I
want you to take the assessment and then
I want you to read the book and you're
gonna begin to see things in a
completely different light and you're so
disciplined you're gonna be fine but you
just gotta get over this doubt about
this job change you're doing a great job
thank you so much for the call you're
gonna get there all right don't move
she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman and
you're listening to the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw the phone number for you to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five all right it is that time
of year where I have to go buy extra
bottles of antacids because it's taxed
I hate and when I say I hate I want you
to understand I'm not going to regret
saying this later today I hate with a
deep abiding passion taxes I hate taxes
but
I also believe we got to pay him
and so a lot of you have questions about
taxes it's it just it can be crazy uh
there's all kinds of new Provisions
every time that Congress does something
and so you need a tax person we've got a
question from one of our viewers and
listeners I'm a new business owner one
of the most important things I need to
do to make bookkeeping for my business
easier oh that's a headache Stacy and I
ran a small business Jade you and Sam
you get it
especially for small business so first
you want to say congratulations on
starting a business uh and bookkeeping
is a lot if you're not already make sure
that you're keeping your personal and
business expenses separate okay that's
really important then you need to create
a regular bookkeeping routine so you're
always on top of tracking your expenses
receipts and invoices
and then finally make sure you're trying
to automate any processes with
accounting software or by working with a
tax professional and I will tell you
Jade I don't I don't know I don't know
what your opinion is
uh I always think it's worth it to pay a
really professional bookkeeper or CPA
yes just Pony up the cash yeah just
there was some real purse strings that's
so true they review your books to reduce
risk eliminate errors and maximize total
tax deductions which is a that's that's
really beautiful when I find out I have
a tax deduction
um I just go hug an animal that's how
happy it makes me makes me happy hey
we've got Ramsey trusted tax Pros uh one
of our endorsed local providers can help
you our team has already vetted them so
you know these people are good at what
they do and they care about taking care
of you head to
ramseysolutions.com
taxpro that's ramsaysolutions.com
slash
tax Pro so there you go and might I add
to that Ken you might as a former
business owner my husband still owns the
business it sometimes you don't want to
pay the money for these things you think
I'll just do it myself and you end up
spending more of your time oh yeah and
losing money in productivity if you
would as opposed to if you would just
pay someone who does this every day who
can do it lickety-split and get it done
for you trust me you will you will lose
money trying to do this yourself because
you won't be as productive as you
normally are actually making money for
the business so just throwing that out
there you get your time
and you get rid of stress yep I mean
that's why you do it worth it yep there
you go hey we have a lot of new people
joining the program all the time whether
you're watching or listening and we want
to say welcome and uh if a lot of this
language and some of the stuff that
we're saying to our callers is new to
you we've got you covered go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and what this is going to
do is quick little survey for us to be
able to know where you are on your
journey within our plan and then we can
get you caught up really quick it's a
wonderful new feature
ramsaysolutions.com get started check it
out all right to the phones we go
Burlington Vermont I feel like I need a
scarf on for this call it's very
exciting Gabe is there Gabe how can we
help
hey there
um
I'm uh 21 years old I'm a full-time
student I'm working full-time as well
and have no debt I'm technically
um on I'm through step one baby step
number one uh have no low debt or
anything like that yet but I know that
you know debt is coming once I'm through
school I'm um I'm doing online school
and I'm expecting about 20
000 in student loans why once I'm done
with my degree why um and the first two
years hold on Gabe we need we need to
know why you're expecting debt to come
to you in the future what does that mean
because because you don't just wander in
take out loans to pay for my tools and
my question is why because you told me
that you're working full-time
and you're doing online school
yeah I'm so I'm living
um you know by myself living in an
apartment so I have expenses a lot to
take care of so much of the income is
taking care of that
um I've also just been putting a lot of
that money in the savings
your big sister who sometimes puts you
in a headlock all right that's what I'm
gonna be right now you got to take these
student loans off the table
you got to take them off the table and
you you you can and I especially love
your situation because out of all the
folks who call us with different types
of
um educational situations I feel like
yours is actually pretty flexible you're
working full-time check that's excellent
you're already knowing hey I got to
start putting money aside and you've
started doing that check now you're also
going to school online dude you have you
can be flexible with this all right you
don't have to just move so quickly that
you throw yourself into debt if it if it
means you got to slow down a little bit
that's okay if it means you need to pick
up extra hours that's all right if it
means you need to get a roommate so that
you can lower your expenses so that you
can throw more money to tuition do you
see what I'm saying we gotta look
through this on a roommate right now
great
um don't work on it do it
in the last in the first two years of my
school I was just really I'm a I'm a
cook and so cool with Summers off
um from school I just pick up a ton of
hours at work and I've been knocking out
any tuition just in full yeah first two
years of school are paid off so why
can't you keep doing that
uh I've taken some advice from somebody
who said you know I was doing that and
not having really a lot of money in my
savings I think I had about three
thousand
um and and so people were saying you
know what you want to do is really try
and put you don't have any savings right
now so try and build your savings and
don't worry about they're wrong but
they're they're wrong but they're not
totally wrong they're they're wrong but
they're not totally wrong you probably
need a thousand that's a tricky thing is
you know to me I don't want to have to I
don't like the idea yeah that's why I
was doing you need a thousand dollars of
emergency fund that's baby step one you
don't have any debt yet and let's keep
it that way so you save your thousand
dollars everything above and beyond that
right now we're saving it up to pay cash
for college because here's the thing you
can save up all the money
you can save up ten thousand twenty
thousand dollars but it's not going to
be your fifteen right now okay so let's
I want to work with some real numbers
how much more tuition do you need to
finish What's the total number I've got
about a year left so what's that 10 000
in loans right now and then I've you
know I've got another year or so
you got ten thousand I thought you said
you didn't have any loans yet
well they I don't have to pay them okay
okay I see once I have to pay until I'm
through with school right well let's go
back I know you got a year left how much
tuition money do you need to finish
uh 12. 12 000. and he's got that in the
bank he's got 15K right yeah so you've
got the cash you finish you need any
more money for tuition
yeah okay and that to me is you know I
would have been I would have paid this
last year off I'm not taking out a loans
I just would have done you know what
I've been doing which is working hard in
my Summers okay but here's the deal
but Gabe you've got some good people in
your life who've given you really bad
advice and what they're saying is don't
spend the 15
which you only need 12. they're saying
don't spend the 12 cash for your last
year just go get a loan and worry about
it later they're wrong they're wrong
they mean well but this is this
conversation is done we've already told
you what we would do what we believe you
should do and so you've now got the 12
000 okay for tuition now you have an
extra three okay that we will say is a
part of your savings in case any kind of
emergency but you're still gonna bust
tail you're gonna work really hard you
know why because I want you to pay the
ten thousand in student loans off
immediately before you even finish yes
that way you're absolutely free you see
the different perspective here
yeah no I get that 100 I I like I said I
think that was kind of the angle I was
taking good you were right
you're you're right you're right and and
what we're telling you is right and I
know somebody somebody's in your ear I
don't know if his mom dad big brother
cousin they they like Kim said since I
was 16. so I haven't really had a lot of
figures in my life who've been able to
help me out with these things
looking out for me Gabe I'm your big
sister here to help you bud and we put
you on the right track and Gabe I would
do what Jade says because if she sees
you in Vermont and she put you in a
headlock whoa watch out I'm telling you
she means business I love you Gabe young
man you're doing great keep on getting
after Jade warshaw great hour thank you
so much I want to thank the team behind
the glass for keeping us on the air but
mostly you America this is your show
this is the Ramsey Show
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
life your work life and your
relationship life I'm Ken Coleman joined
by my colleague Jade warshaw the number
to jump in is
[Music]
888-825-5225-88-825-5225 let's go to
Dallas Texas Ruth is on the line Ruth
how can we help
yes hi thanks for having me on the show
I'm a huge fan I'm calling today because
I am looking to lead my full-time job to
pursue what's been a passion project of
mine I'm a marketing director currently
at a financial firm and I'd like to
become a content creator I'm creating
digital courses and eventually lead to
motivational speaking and
clone all different types of content
great what kind of content
specifically what what solution are you
providing to what problem
uh women empowerment I'll be starting
with the course on Transitions and also
launching out from there helping women
in different years basically pursue
their dreams okay so I hear what you
want to do what specifically do you want
our Insight on
um I just want to make sure I considered
all the angles so we've been saving for
about 18 months where baby steps four
five and six oh good uh we have just six
month emergency funds same for a college
kids college fund he's a five-year-old
and we have about a 50 000 in a
transition fund set up set aside just
for any extra expenses business expenses
to launch it however like we'll be
leaving you know taking two-thirds of
our family income off the table whoa all
right now that's where I want to jump in
because that was the first question I
was going to ask is do you need your
income and the answer is sort of right
because you guys are in great financial
position but I don't know that I would
recommend that you even consider this
big of a pay cut there are times where
I'm absolutely saying you have to do it
in order to get where you want to go you
don't have to do this and I'll tell you
why
if you could completely walk away today
and you didn't need to make any income
my advice on starting this new Venture
would be the same and I would tell you
to start small and grow slow not just
because of the financial ramifications
but from a Content development
standpoint
clarifying your voice is a unique
process
and and I've done it and so I'm going to
speak from experience you know I had a
vision for what I'm doing at Ramsey
solutions to help people discover their
potential to meet their potential and
make a contribution that matters deeply
to them now I I knew that that was the
Mountaintop but I did not have the
methodology that I have today there were
so many things that I had to just test
and try and fail and and and scrap and
and just kind of go well I'm going to
try that and well that feels really good
at 10 o'clock at night at 9 A.M the next
morning it felt like a block of Velveeta
cheese I don't want anybody to know that
I was thinking about saying it that way
it's that kind of stuff to where you got
to throw stuff against the wall so my
point is
if that's the advice I'd give you if
finances weren't an issue at all it's
absolutely the same advice when finances
are there so here's what I'm really
telling you to do I'd start and I think
you already I think you already have but
I don't think that you I don't think you
walk away today and I'm not sure you
walk away six months from now what I'd
like to see you six months from now is
where you've launched your first course
just one just one course Ruth are you
already replacing some of your income
with this business Endeavor or have you
made have you been able to make any
money yet doing this I
I've written a book a year ago
self-published and I'm making money
through that how much just being a
full-time mom not much just not much I
might set up in 10 000. can you can
correct me but I might set a a goal of a
percentage like I want to be replacing
this much of my previous income before I
pull the trigger on exiting from your
current situation
is that fair yeah
I'm just exhausted right at the end of
doing my day job right and here's the
deal that's why I'm telling you keep
doing the day job and do this thing on
the side let's go through all the
testing and all the failing and all the
improving without any pressure at all
because here's the deal if you work so
hard to save up six months of your
current income I don't know that you're
gonna have a whole lot left to give in
other words I tell people all the time
you cannot give what you do not have
and when you're emotionally and
physically exhausted you're not going to
be at your creative best to create
content and a digital course and all
those things that are really going to
meet women where they are my point is
take the pressure off
there will come a time because you're in
baby steps four five and six because you
have the discipline to get there that
you will be able to step into this thing
full time now it's not the time and with
a five-year-old not with the fact that
you're exhausted trying to get up all
that savings let's just launch a course
this year let's launch one course we do
it at night and weekends when we don't
have other things and we take our time
because we don't have Financial pressure
do you understand what I'm saying and
why I'm saying that
but I'm exhausted from the day job but
here's the thing let me let me let me
get right on your level because uh
before I came here to Ramsey uh back in
2020 before let's go with 2019. uh I was
working full-time full-time um in our
business and then I also did uh about 15
to 20 hours a week in Ministry so I was
working right like crazy 2020 I started
something very similar to what you're
talking about it was online deal more
feastless fam it was all about money
food I struck up a full production TV
show to go on YouTube it was a lot of
work and I did it all on the side had to
do the social for it I did it all on the
side I was exhausted I've never worked
so hard in my entire life but do you
know what it does it tests yeah it tests
that passion to see if you really love
it and and I love what Kenneth saying
you do I didn't have to make money off
of it I just had to see could I do it
does it work I was trying stuff I was
throwing spaghetti at the wall to see if
it would stick and there is something
really beautiful about that you're not
going to be in this phase forever that's
right you're going to learn something
from this well and Ruth here's here's
what I want you to hear I'm not in any
way discounting that the day job is
exhausting you because then you're a
mama and then and then you're trying to
do this thing but here's what I'm saying
we cheat the dream for a little bit
longer
now what I mean by that is
I've got to take care of me so Ruth you
got to take care of you so when the day
job is exhausting you plus being a mama
you gotta treat yourself very well and
so if we have to spend more time nights
and weekends resting and recovering
and a little bit less time on the dream
let's say developing that first course
that's okay do you hear me you do not
want to flame out trying to balance it
all you can't balance it you can't right
and you can't here's what I would say to
all the mamas out there you can do it
all just not at the same time and that's
my encouragement here's the deal stay in
the the day job a little longer let's
take care of yourself a little bit more
and just if I'm only spending an hour a
weekend I'm making this up working on
that digital course that's okay but
let's launch one thing let's test it
take all the pressure off by the way
you'll find that when the pressure's off
your creativity is so much better as
well thank you so much Ruth you're
amazing you're a hero and we're here for
you don't move more Ramsey show right
around the corner
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Applause]
you have joined the conversation here on
the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me and we're here to help
you win in your life your money life
your work life and your relationship
life so excited that you've joined us
888-825-5225 is the number
888-825-5225 and and Jade and I are on a
high we we uh landed this morning and uh
drove in to do the Big Show here today
but we were in Austin Texas last night
Jade and in a word
how would you describe that crowd
dazzling I knew she wouldn't disappoint
I was going to say scintillating so I
love it I wasn't
I just tried to go one lap you went up I
cheated but I like dazzling it was a
great crowd Building Wealth life uh we
are in the middle of this tour we've
gotten Indianapolis in the books Austin
in the books and we've got two more
cities Salt Lake City Utah on April the
24th and Anaheim California on May the
second you're new to us and you're going
what is Building Wealth live well this
is a great live event where we help you
with basic money principles so whether
or not you're in a strong economy a a
okay economy or a bad economy it doesn't
affect you because you are winning with
money and you are recession-proof uh and
you're Building Wealth and that's why we
call it Building Wealth live uh tickets
have been selling out quickly both of
the events we've had so far including
Austin Texas last night was sold out so
you better move the tickets start at
just 49
ramseysolutions.com events is is the way
to get the tickets
ramseysolutions.com slash events and uh
who's in Salt Lake City it will be
Christina Ellis Dave Ramsey not you
Rachel Cruz yeah
and uh George Campbell I think so yeah
and then and then in Anaheim it is uh
Dave Ramsey myself Dr John deloney and
Christina Ellis now let me tell you when
John and Ken get together oh boy they do
this thing in the pre-show I had not
witnessed it it was Legend it was a
legend that I heard about and I got to
witness it here in Austin they intervene
in these people's lives in such a major
way it is really something to watch so
when you get tickets try to get the Via
get whatever it takes to go to the
pre-show right right Ken you're very
kind we had fun yeah and we you know
it's just real you saw it life happens
people just come up and and they they
get real with us and you know we get
real with them it was like Maury I was
like this is this is different it is fun
John and I John and I feel very very
blessed to do that it's it's um it's
very rewarding because of how real it
gets it does and you saw it it's
palpable it's fun a lot of fun so anyway
we'd love to see you there
ramseysolutions.com events all right you
ready to take some more calls let's go
let's go let's go to the City of
Brotherly Love hey Philadelphia
Pennsylvania
is on the line Ro how can we help
hi um yes I have about 300 000 in my
401k plan and I'd just like to know what
can I
put it in to make it grow
well the fact that you have a 401k is an
excellent place to start that's good
um do you currently know how it's being
invested
or are you kind of just like I just
picked whatever they
they had for me
yeah just pick whatever whatever they
have for me okay well what we would
suggest there's a way that we think is
the the best possible way to do your
investing and that is to have your
contribution spread evenly over four
types of mutual funds so do you know are
you in mutual funds or do you you said
you're not sure at all what you're
invested in correct
yes I'm not sure okay so what I would
say get with a smart Vester and our
smart investor Pros they do everything
the way we teach it but I don't want you
to just go in there and say hey give me
the Ramsay right I want you to
understand what they're investing your
money in so that you have a great
understanding of it and they will have
the heart of a teacher to teach this to
you as well but you want to have your
money spread equally over four types of
mutual funds and I'm glad you're asking
this question Ro it's a great question I
get it all the time on social media
people say where am I supposed to invest
my money to get a 10 return and I say
gosh you know if you could just
understand this you want to spread it
over growth Funds growth and income
funds aggressive growth and
International
so what I mean by that when I say that
is if we're talking about growth and
income I mean these are big companies
that we've just grown up with I mean
these are your big boys that you know
they're making money no matter what and
they're also paying out dividends that
you're reinvesting so it's like double
the fun right and then you've got your
growth
funds again it's a big uh sampling of
all of these large companies and growth
funds we know again they're making money
they're not as big as the big the big
boys but they're big and we know that we
can count on a return and then you've
got your aggressive growth a lot of
times that's uh Tech funds some more
startup things it's a little bit more
aggressive and so we're putting 25
percent there and then we've of course
got our international funds
um and you want to choose something
there don't necessarily choose a global
fund because sometimes that might
include some unite some things from the
states as well but International is what
you're looking for and so that's how we
spread it out and we do that so that
we're not putting all of our eggs in one
basket right and so that's the way to do
it and we're choosing mutual funds that
are outperforming
the S P 500 okay I don't want to get too
deeply into that but that's what we're
seeking to do because a lot of people
might say oh just park it in some index
funds well that's not bad but we want to
do better than that and we can do better
than that so that's kind of hopefully
I'm keeping the cookies on a shelf where
we can all understand and everybody
knows what we're doing here does that
make sense for you
yes getting there yeah what about rra
funds IRAs okay so an IRA is not a fund
it's the basket that's holding your
Investments so right now you've got a
401k your 401k is a investment account
that's offered through your workplace
and if you did not have in retirement
offered through your workplace you could
get a very similar basket to hold your
Investments that's called an IRA and
it's basically you going as an
individual to get the Investments as
opposed to you going through your
workplace does that make sense
yes so if you wanted to you could
contribute to your 401k
through your employer and you could also
probably go out and get a Roth IRA on
your own and contribute to that as well
oh okay so you've got lots of you've got
options here but it's great that you're
uh contributing to your 401k the way we
say to do it here when it comes to
investing is if you've got any sort of
match
with your IRA through your company you
will invest up to your match so let's
say you got three percent or five
percent you invest up to your match and
then you would go outside and open up
your own Roth IRA and fully contribute
to that or until you run out of money
and then if you still have money left
that you can invest you go back to the
401K and finish it there so Roth or I'm
sorry match beats Roth
and go on like that does that make sense
I don't want to overwhelm you but I want
to kind of make sure you understand
since you're asking great questions
uh now listen Ro here's what I want you
to do I want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com okay and I want you
to click on trusted Services right at
the top of the website and I want you to
then go and click on investing in
retirement and I want you to connect
with three to four
of our smartvester Pros these are
world-class men and women who we have
vetted who we trust and they actually
what Jay just laid out for you is a lot
for you to take in but they can explain
it even further and you want to make
sure that you understand it fully but
get a smart Master Pro if you don't
already have one to get your strategy
you don't do this by yourself is the
point I'm making and there's a great
blog we're going to put in the show
notes it's the best of retirement funds
so anybody who's listening if you want
to know more about the mutual funds that
I was talking about if you want to know
more about how I was saying uh match
beats rothbeach traditional just check
out that link in the show notes and you
can learn all that you want to learn I
hope that was helpful for somebody it is
and and again we want to make sure that
people understand that this program the
smartvester pro yeah is is a program
that has helped so many people because
those people that are listed on our
website have to still earn your business
so when you go sit down with them
don't just say well I I'm here yeah and
you seem like a nice person because uh
you're a Ramsey smart Mr Pro I'm gonna
let you take over my no they've got to
explain it even further as Jay did at a
high level to where you understand it
and you go okay because you're in charge
you need help but you're in charge so
again anybody that's new or been
listening watching for a while go get a
smart Master Pro to help you with your
retirement and investment strategy
you'll thank us I promise all right
don't move more of your calls coming up
she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
helping you win with your money
in your work and in your relationships
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
Jade warshaw joins me the phone number
to jump in on the conversation is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's Friday afternoon there's got to be
some like messy toxic work stuff out
there that you just want me to get my
hands dirty we'll change your name and
your location we do that on the Ken
Coleman show all the time there's some
nasty stuff out there so we're standing
by let's go I think Jade wants to wade
into one of these as well I love it so
there you go but first today's question
comes from Julie from the official Ken
Coleman community on Facebook is it ever
wise to give more than two weeks notice
when leaving a job
if you can
and what I mean by that
is you can give them that much notice so
if you want to give them six weeks or
two months or whatever that is so if you
can do it and it doesn't mess anything
up but it's not risk in any way it's not
creating tension with the new company
that you've committed to if you can
and you believe you should
because you feel like I'm giving them
the extra time to prepare
uh allowing me to transition well so the
person who follows me can step in a
little easier so and you believe you
should then the answer is yes so if you
can and you believe you should yes it's
wise but I would I would also say
don't feel guilt
and I I it's kind of fun I've answered
enough of those on my show live to know
that Julie's probably feeling guilty and
she's kind of wanting to know should I
give him a little bit more is that wise
because she doesn't want to burn a
bridge and I understand that and that's
a really really uh no Noble uh reason
but but don't feel this that you have to
do this if company's been good to you
but it's time to move
didn't move with your head held high but
uh yeah sure it's wise some people worry
about their replacement too they kind of
think oh man I don't want to leave them
in a Lurch what do you say to that Ken
when when people are it's not your
problem it's not your problem it's not
your problem now you do what you can do
so whatever that looks like spreadsheet
saved on the computer uh messages on the
desk that say hey here's the process
where is that required or is that above
and beyond that's above and beyond okay
I don't think it's required the company
will tell you what's required they'll
kind of say hey we'd like you to do this
before you leave and I think your class
act and you say sure I want to leave
well so this question is is it wise yeah
it's just the wrong question is is it
required no would it be a nice thing
classy thing sure as long as it meets
those two requirements but other than
that
it is what it is I mean look companies
can you could go in and give them six
weeks and go we want you to leave Friday
oh
I mean good riddance right so leave well
yeah whatever leaving well looks like
that's fine all right let's get back to
the phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five Buffalo New York is
where Janelle is waiting for us Janelle
how can we help
I have a quick question my husband and I
are kind of going like we're on the same
page but we can't really decide
um if we are making a good call or you
know if our decision leaning is in the
right direction so
um our take-home pay is about 9 500 a
month we currently rent an apartment for
um and our lease is up in May and rent
is going to be going up to 13.85.
um we're in baby step two we have uh
fifteen thousand dollars left on a car
and thirty thousand dollars left in
student loans
um and we're projected to pay everything
off by December
um and we also have eight thousand
dollars in savings that's very good
um my question is we obviously know
we're a little bit away from buying a
house because we want to be debt free
have the emergency fund saved and also
enough money for a hefty down payment
um so we were wondering if it like town
homes in our area going for about
eighteen hundred dollars a month and we
were wondering if it would be wise of us
to rent a town home for a couple years
and that way we have more space as if we
were in a house but we're not jumping
into a house with you know barely any
down payment you know right after we pay
off debt yeah I applaud you for wanting
to do you know a home purchase in the
smartest way I applaud the fact that
you're not in a hurry because so many
people are are moving fast they end up
doing something real dumb so I love that
um thanks for all the information too I
had a quick question you've got a lot in
savings I heard you say you're in baby
step two but you have 8K in savings
what's the deal with that
yeah
we're just afraid just work just doing
your own plans
no no actually we're taking us
after next week yay yay hey Hey Ho Let's
Go
um so the 8K I do have questions about
it
um you know I I have a feeling I know
why you have it there but I want to
challenge you to work the steps as the
steps are written thank you yeah because
they here's the thing and I if you feel
like pause about it let me just remind
you Millions
Janelle millions of people have used
this plan to get out and it works it
works when you work it and it works
fastest
and most effectively when you do the
plan as written Jade's being very nice
I'm I'm gonna jump I'm being nice
because she's she's gonna be in my class
and I gotta face her I gotta face her
again on the first so I get to ask the
hard questions so that Jade is still
super wonderful to you because she is
okay if we took the seven thousand
that we teach you to take out of the 8K
in savings and put it towards the debt
how would that change the payoff date
from December of this year what would it
move it to
well actually it would stay the same
because what our well no no it won't no
no it won't
no it won't because we were going to
drain it at the end of the month once we
pay our like we have eight eight
thousand in savings and at the end of
the month we were going to be down to 8
000 left on the car so we were going to
drain it at that point oh so you planned
on using it so we planned on using it
okay forgive forgive us you know because
we we came we came in hot we got bad
information but now we're on the same
page okay I probably should have been
more precise yeah okay great great plan
now back to your other question because
I I did get sidetracked by that 8K back
to your original question about the
renting yeah I would rent
um it's expensive to rent right now
let's just be honest and and people feel
funky about renting because they feel
like they're throwing money down the
drain and this and that and that's
really not the case it's a small price
to pay for doing things the right way
and to for doing things um in the most
secure way and for you the reason is
being able to build up a solid down
payment so that you can actually get
into a home that you like a home that
you can afford you know where where the
the payment is no more than 25 of your
take-home pay right on a 15-year fixed
that's what you're looking to do and um
yeah do what it takes to get there and
if that means uh renting a town home now
you said doing that to get a little bit
more space uh is that necessary because
I kind of like the idea I mean if you
want to get there faster what's wrong
with increasing your rent by 85 dollars
I mean it's just 85 as opposed to 585
that was my question you would what do
you need space for
yeah I mean I guess the thing was is
um stayed here for another year because
that was another idea we were talking
about is if we stayed here for a year
and then it would be next May at that
point we would more than likely have our
emergency fund saved up but probably not
enough for a down payment you didn't
answer my question you didn't answer my
question there's no there's no point in
moving up and you don't need space yeah
there's no point in moving up to a town
home
let me do simple math let me do simple
math if you stay where you are you're
looking at a little over what 600 a
month right at 600 a month
do the math on that 6 times 12. yeah
last I checked that was seven thousand
dollars
yes that you're putting towards debt and
filling up that emergency fund just
because you want a little nicer Place
let's be honest it's okay to admit it
yes I wouldn't do it I would stay right
where you're at and go ahead and just
slow
can I always tell people what I would do
because here's the thing it's a free
country they're going to leave this call
and do what they want to do I oh you're
right Jade warshaw the one who's on the
air would not do it the one who's given
the advice would
stay where you're at I'd go ahead and
choke down you know they're going to
raise the rent that sucks go ahead and
choke down that 85 dollars a month raise
that they're gonna do and uh stay there
you are going to reach your goals so
much faster if you just hold on a little
bit longer
all right now if you told me you're
pregnant with triplets or quadruplets
then I might say okay you might need a
little bit more space
but uh you know for now just hang out
where you're at you're doing right
you're doing everything good you're not
in a rush and a lot of us can take a
little bit of a lesson from you on that
one it's a focused game focus on the
money you're saving and getting the good
use not that nicer place this is the
ramage
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the Ramsay show continues I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me in studio
we're here for you
we're answering your questions about
your life specifically your money
questions your work and professional
career questions relationship questions
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number
888-825-5225 Andrew is on the line in
Las Vegas Andrew how can we help
I can Jade how are you guys doing good
how are you
uh good thank you
um so I just had a roundabout blessing
of sorts my car which I made the mistake
of Finance about two years ago was uh
just recently totaled and after the
total loss settlement pays off what's
left in the loan I'll have about 4 700
left over now I did already do another
dumb thing and finance another car but
this was at least less stupid it was
less stupid because I bought a 25 year
old beater of a truck for about four
grand so you finance the four grand
I I did yes
for sure so do I use that leftover money
to pay off the truck or do I just work
through the debt snowball and pay off uh
I think it would pay off my three
smallest credit cards first yeah let's
work it through the debt snowball I wish
that you had you know waited if you
could have and just translated that into
a cash card but at this point we're here
it's not a giant amount of money so
let's just work it through the debt
snowball and just go through it like
that how much debt do you have total
uh total it's about 14
700. okay and do you have a do you have
baby step one in place the thousand
dollars
I do yes okay great great yeah then
that's exactly what I would do
um and cut the cards up bro
yeah yeah
and uh no I haven't I need to do that
Andrew do you have do you have them with
you right now
okay let's do this yeah I'm gonna
challenge you I'm gonna challenge you
you got a pair of scissors near you we
gonna do this right now
Andrew all right
and I like to make my own sound effects
so here's what I want you to do I want
you to get it's fine the audience loves
it will I promise uh what I want you to
do is get the credit card right up to
the phone yes and I want you to take the
snooze the snoozers what am I saying
when you pull them out and I want you to
make the sound and just let's clip them
right up close to the phone let's see if
we can hear it do you got the first card
okay now do you have a card in your hand
now
and and while you're looking for it
while you're looking for them tell us
what type of credit cards they are is it
a discover it's what I was Capital One
what you got in the uh yeah some Capital
One there's a Chase Sapphire ironically
a Chase Freedom oh Lord oh we're about
ready to give let me tell you y'all know
y'all know the country is in more credit
card debt than ever ever before highest
ever and these folks are defaulting more
than ever yeah because we think and and
I'm not harping on you Andrew while
you're out here getting your credit
cards so that you can cut them up but
people get they they get them thinking
oh I'm gonna do the points or I'm gonna
this was my famous last words I'm gonna
pay it off every month
um
how'd that work out it didn't work out
because what happens is you start that
way and then there's that pink pea coat
at Express that you have to have that
was my thing pea coat or your level or
your boyfriend has a job interview and
he needs a new suit yeah he does what'd
you do taking down the Men's Warehouse I
took him down to S and K and I bought
him two for 200 Ken Coleman
I bought him
a little shine on it y'all remember what
I'm talking about okay so that's the
point can we Andrew please tell me you
found your wallet I'm good to go okay
okay pull the card out all right you got
the scissors the scissors
all right let's go right now tell us the
card and then cut it get close to the
phone what's the first card we're
cutting
all right this guy here is a uh Capital
One Platinum okay everybody quiet now go
here we go
[Music]
a
head did you hear that I heard it
cracked I'll be honest folks it was a
little bit uh it was a little bit
disappointing no Ken I heard it I heard
it crack in half that's not your fault
Andrew it sounded like you were
searching around in the closet for a for
a shoe tree or something no he he cut it
I heard it go through when it goes
through the thick part where the numbers
are I heard okay all right now let's go
ahead let's go ahead and cut the other
ones real quick we don't even have to
have the sound effect what's the second
card
right uh this is let's see City American
Advantage American Airlines okay I'm
gonna count you down you ready oh yeah
you ready to cut yeah three two one I'm
ready three two one
good
uh Yep this is a nope that's my debit
card need that this is the sound this is
the sound of Freedom careful not the
debit card we need that one what do you
guys this last one right
uh yeah I got two more okay come on come
on come on through Andrew let's just
speed the process up here this is a
plastic to me Dave used to do this all
the time so here we go give me give me
the cut go three two one all right
this feels so good yeah all right cut
the other two up Let's do let's put the
two together the last two and cut
through both of them at the same time
what are they
all right we've got a tap fire Chase
Sapphire and then uh another Capital One
oh fantastic they're lined up what's in
your wallet no all right nothing okay
cut them up ready three two one go
and now what I'm
what I want down
credit card debt free
credit card
for your credit card I'm credit card
free okay we're gonna count it down we
got Andrew from Las Vegas Nevada he has
cut up five credit cards come on Andrew
count it down give him three two one
three oh three two one
I'm credit card free all right it's a
start it's a start
he's on his way folks we just this poor
guy we just manipulated him into all of
this but just somebody needed to do it
for you I know that's right now you now
listen now those cards they're destroyed
don't ever use them again close you're
done you paid them off Roger that call
him up close the accounts let's do it
the right way to call each one today
close them up
hey you're such a good sport thanks for
for doing that with us you know you know
that's what Dave you I don't know how
many years ago he started calling those
plasectomies but Andrew just did it and
there is no pain medication he just went
ahead and cut them up right there that
was kind of fun that was real that was
real deal right there that's what you
call live and in action wow so why is
that important Jade that yeah and again
it's symbolic yes because his accounts
are still open he's gonna pay him off we
believe today in closing but why is that
symbolic it's a big deal because for a
lot of people that's a safety net it's
the fallback instead of trusting that if
you follow this plan it will work for
you and and trusting that you can
control your behavior yeah because if
you keep those credit cards in your
wallet what you're telling yourself is I
don't trust myself to stay on a budget
I don't trust myself to do what I said I
was gonna do which is take my extra
money and put it towards debt I don't
trust myself to understand the
difference between a need and a want
I don't trust myself to understand that
an emergency is not Uncle Boo Boo's
wedding
you know what I'm saying and when you
when you do what Andrew did and you take
out the scissors and you cut up those
cards you're saying I trust myself yeah
I can I can make good adult decisions
and follow through yeah so that's
something that's happening on the inside
and we are going to see the outside
effect in his bank account and in his
money and he's going to be able to go on
and pay off debt and build wealth and do
all those things but it really starts
with something inside yeah I love that
and sure and I love that he called in
going you know what I realized what I
did was dumb yeah I totaled the car he
didn't repeat the mistakes he didn't and
his own opportunity you know he said hey
I realized what in the past all right
what do I do and that's the spirit and
the reason I'm calling this out is we
had some fun with Andrew but I hope that
most of you get some real inspiration
from Andrew to say there's no shame in
your game you made some dumb Financial
moves your life isn't over you can fix
this you can start fresh and this young
man is doing it Andrew you are awesome
so proud I love you bro appreciate you
calling in and having some fun I like to
do that more we need to we need to get
some like mics on that and get that
clipping sound a little better but he
did his best Hey Jake warshaw great hour
I want to thank the team behind the
glass that keeps us on the air and you
America for tuning in this is your show
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
life your work life and in your
relationship life phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm Ken Cole and I'm joined
by my colleague The Fabulous Jade
warshaw AAA
825-5225 and we're gonna stay right here
as we start off our phone calls this
hour in the shadows of Nashville
Tennessee Dewey is on the line Dewey how
can we help
what's up
AI tools since they came out and they're
all very cool and they've increased my
productivity by a lot yeah but I I
wonder if like my job as a data engineer
I feel like it's going to be fully
replaced by AI in the future hold on
you're really hold on one second because
you're really smart and I know you're
smarter than me all right so I want to
know what you are basing that concern on
specifically how AI is going to replace
a data engineer
so uh like Chad GPT has made my job
easier and I know like data analysts
there is another tool out that I can't
remember the name of now but you can
hook your database to that tools and it
will
um it will run any type of question you
have for you you can ask it questions
things like that so basically anything a
data analyst would do this tool is doing
but like even as a data engineer I see
that same thing happening with data
engineering too
um it's already happened I feel like in
some ways because what used to take me
five hours to figure out I can figure
out in five minutes okay
absolutely but what is your role
in giving information to chat B chat
goodness GPT so what's your role because
it doesn't do it on its own you've got a
role you're doing some input yes or no
yeah I yeah and then hold on hold on I'm
just walking through this with you and
then when you put the input in and chat
gbt gives you information back what do
you do with that
um I take it and I do something else
with it like I make it I make it run end
to end right you see so my point is is
AI is not going to threaten people like
you because AI will simply be a tool for
people like you it will not replace you
because it cannot do what you can do
true or false
oh it can't but in 10 years I think it
will be able to foreign
sure and I can't I'm not going to argue
with you on that I would just tell you
that AI it will never truly replace
humans it cannot it can Implement things
that humans want it to implement it can
add to and we're going to integrate it
but let's get to the heart of your
question because there's something
there's a there's a fear there's a doubt
underneath this and it's forming a
question what is it that you want to to
know what can we help you with yeah
I got laid off in November oh I'm sorry
yeah so now my question is like did I
even continue in this career or try to
build a new career or a combination of
both well because like yes go ahead
because what
because I feel like like if there's
hundred thousand data engineering jobs
today maybe in five years there'll only
be 10 000 of those because sad GPT and
other AI tools can help like make life
easier all right so I'm going to ask you
two simple questions and then we'll
start to come up with a path forward do
you still enjoy the work of being an
engineer let's pull away from just data
engineering but the engineering mindset
and the type of work that Engineers do
do you enjoy the work
yes all right are you really good at the
work
you're good now listen the question is
this skill set you have now and the
experience you've had up to this moment
is that transferable
in any other part of the Working World
yes or no
yes yes
um yes yeah all right so the mindset now
is less about do I stay
in data engineering or do I move into a
different part of engineering or do I
move completely to a completely
different industry and I take all the
engineers skill sets and experience and
apply that there it's less about that
because we know you can do all three the
answer is excuse me the question we're
looking for is what is it that I want to
do and if you want to stay in data
engineering I would stay in it and I get
back up on the horse and keep going and
it sucks that you got laid off but that
happens especially in your world
certainly in big tech jobs where they'll
hire up and then we've seen a pattern of
them laying off a lot of people that has
nothing to do with you that's the cycle
so maybe you want to look into you know
maybe smaller companies small businesses
that are still can do very very large
Revenue small business classification in
America goes up to I believe 499 maybe
599 employees so you can kind of guard
yourself from some of that up and down
volatility that we see with public
companies but you just have to ask
yourself what is it that I want to do
what kind of work do I want to do and
then we say all right where can I do
that and we don't worry about things
that we cannot control which is is AI
going to replace me I think that's
further off than you believe and I think
you'll also get way more evidence of
that and it'll be very very obvious as
well I don't think it's going to sneak
up on you what do you think about that
friends
um I I worry about that because like my
my brother works at Google and he had to
sell off all his talks in January
because everybody at Google is freaking
out about Chad PPP
um okay hold on I feel like we went down
we went back down the same path area
what I'm saying is is you're scared but
I'm also asking you to acknowledge that
you have value in so many different
places that you don't need to worry
about chat GPT and artificial
intelligence is not your enemy you have
opportunity you're focusing on an enemy
and not opportunity it's a mindset this
is all all I can coach you on on this
particular call is mindset but do you
see what I'm asking you to see do you
see the opportunity versus the enemy I
do okay now opportunity Dewey
opportunity and you have so much to give
the world so let's start looking at
practical things like where can I do
what I do
that's it that's all I want you looking
at where can I do what I do and then who
do I know over there or who do I know
that knows somebody over there and so
now we're getting very tactical and
we're looking to replace our income and
do something that we know that we're
very good at doing and we're not going
to worry about long off storms and stuff
like that it's just a recipe for fear
Jade and then what happens is when all I
think about is the enemy I can't move
forward because I'm only looking at the
enemy and I live scared that's right you
know there's a progression to these
things and thank God because during that
progression you have the time to adapt
yes and you see where you're in roads
are and you see where your opportunities
are so it's not just it's from here to
complete Doom and Gloom that's right you
got a progression and you have the
ability to adapt Dewey you've got this
you have so much value believe it and
act like it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is my colleague and
she joins me this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey we
have so many people that are joining the
show all the time and those of you
who've been listening and watching for a
while and we would love for you to help
us spread the word if this show is
adding any value to you imagine how we
could help other people and you're the
greatest source of marketing prowess
that exists on the planet just good
old-fashioned word of mouth so would you
consider subscribing leaving a review
and sharing the show with a friend or
family member we would appreciate it but
can I just say
um
this is not an invitation for somebody
who disagrees with us or doesn't like us
to just go drop trash in the comments if
it doesn't do anything for you
then don't say nothing don't say
anything it's kind of like my Grandmama
used to say if you can't say something
good don't say anything come on Kenneth
and uh it's kind of personal for you too
welcome to the welcome to the club oh I
should say I got initiated into the club
it's funny the very first time I was on
here with Dave we know we did a little
social media post and a guy came in
there and he was like so because you
know I told a little of my story and the
guy says so basically all you have to do
is be an idiot with money and Dave
Ramsey will hire you yeah and I'm
thinking yeah I did dumb stuff with
money yeah and then a couple days later
lady comes on and says who would ever
listen to you
and I'm like okay okay okay okay because
you paid off almost 500 Grand in debt
and changed your life okay that's why
people would listen to you because you
know what it's like to dig a deep hole
and then get out yeah man I told so
that's who I want to hear from by the
way I don't want to hear from somebody
who don't have any scars oh man when Sam
and I were getting out of debt so for
those of you who don't know my husband
and I we got married uh and soon after
you know your student loans don't become
due until about six months after you
actually graduate so we didn't really
realize what we had combined so about
six eight months into marriage we
realized we were deeply deeply deeply
into debt most of it was student loan
debt uh 280 000 of it with student loans
and the rest two cars that we couldn't
afford 20 000 in credit cards in the end
we had 460 000 wow in debt and when we
started when we started I got a little
bit of an attitude because I know folks
some folks have made me a little bit
salty kin so I have a little bit of
attitude in my voice when we started our
income was 30k oh because we were
musicians fresh out I worked at a
clothing store
and you know we had Big Dreams and it
was like okay what are we gonna do put
up or you know buck up or yeah get out
of here you know something so we started
working and um we were working for a
Cruise Line Traveling all around the
world uh we ended up starting a business
to try to get our income up and it
worked and we did any and everything we
could in between our normal music jobs
to earn money can you have a place to
live or were you just live in on a
cruise show we were okay so you go out
there for just a couple of days at a
time and then you fly home it's a lot of
flights and we were living in a
townhouse and we got roommates
yeah married folks with roommates with
roommates because you were hardly ever
there uh we were there enough we were
there enough so so like you were like
the real life Friends episode uh it was
it you know you know they were always
there yeah I'll be there yeah they were
there all the time and uh we did that to
save 600 bucks a month and we did all
sorts of things Ken yeah we didn't have
a we sold all of our furniture
slept on an air mattress that's all you
had we slept on an air mattress for five
years Ken Coleman so when when people
come at me and and they don't they don't
think I'm qualified to teach this a man
with an experience is never at the mercy
of a man with an opinion because I did
this Sam warshaw Jade warshaw we did
this you guys have long-term
Chiropractic Care not dude you were okay
when you're in your 20s you're made out
of rubber man you can do whatever you
had in the uh town home was an air
mattress we had an air mattress for a
good minute and I remember when we saved
up enough cash and we bought these faux
like you know the faux leather oh yeah
that when you can't afford the the
Italian leather oh yeah we had these to
stick to it yeah you're like when you
get up to go to the bathroom when you're
watching a game you know what I mean and
the leg goes like this yeah right off
the top but we were so excited to have
them we slept on them like we were like
I'm Sleepless yeah of course but I'm
saying you know the sacrifice to win to
walk through the baby steps and to walk
through baby step two it took us seven
and a half years to do that Ken and
that's why she's actually here because
she did it I don't want to take advice
from a professor I don't want to take a
business class from a professor that has
never run a successful business so why
would you take Financial advice from
somebody who's never failed financially
yeah and then had to win yeah
yeah that's something all you haters out
there don't get me started on the
kitchen
haterade I mean they're they're cowards
because they like to fire stuff from the
safety of the keyboard they'd never say
it to your face no and so I don't listen
to cowards in fact the the team over on
the Ken Coleman show they're instructed
all negative comments
I don't mean like healthy constructively
well yeah because we do want to learn
from yeah yeah but I mean just the nasty
like you're an idiot whatever well sure
I wouldn't argue with you for two
seconds about it and that's the thing
but I'm not going to read that crap so
it goes immediately into the deleted
folder so if you think you're really
getting at us you're not yeah take your
Venom somewhere else because we're
really trying to help you yeah we hear
you guys you guys are you what you're
going through we care about that and
have walked through it and have walked
through it so the things that we're
telling you is things that we have done
things that we have tried things that we
have felt we're right there with you man
if you're in baby step two and if you're
in what I call the six figure Freedom
Club where you're trying to pay off six
figures or more of debt I see you man I
I feel you I feel your pain I feel the
struggle when you when it's Friday night
like tonight and everybody else is going
out what'd you do on Friday night take
me back since we got the air mattress
what was Friday night when you guys were
broke nacho night
make some nachos at the crib
hold on because you're a good cook what
was old school broke Jade nachos was it
the the shredded cheese melted or was it
real nacho cheese no no it was honestly
it was whatever we had whatever we had
in the in the refrigerator that's what I
was gonna figure out something to make I
did not so some nights it was like vegan
nachos sunlight it was protein nachos no
no it was we we keep it clean it's
always vegan don't get it twisted Ken
well this will be trying to get it
twisted I'm actually asking because
you're a clean folks don't know you're a
super cleaner so how do you eat clean
when you're broke because if you're
getting the government cheese for my
nachos
you gotta stay on the outside of the
grocery store because that's where all
the healthy stuff is fruits vegetables
all the produce and then if you're gonna
go on the inner aisles that's where you
get your proteins so your nuts your
beans that kind of thing right and you
buy what's on sale and what you can't
buy fresh you buy Frozen and what you
can't afford to buy Frozen you buy in a
can that's how you do it if you can't
afford to buy the fresh spinach you buy
the Frozen spinach right and you just
work on down if you can't get the the
fresh carrots you buy the Frozen carrots
if you can't get the Frozen carrots then
you get the canned carrots and you just
go on down the line like that that's
good but don't nobody no one can tell me
that oh there's no way to eat healthy
when you don't have money you do not
have to buy ramen noodles you do not
have to buy McDonald's because
McDonald's is not cheap anymore by the
way you go through uh fast food with
kids yeah you're spending seventy
dollars by the way I saw an article
recently of a dude who uh literally
forgot hey like he moved from somewhere
and a friend of his brought his coat
back to him it's like a trench coat been
two years
he gets the trench coat
hangs out in the closet a couple days
later he puts it on puts his hand in the
pocket that's a true story
and he feels something crinkling in
there and he pulls it out it's a
McDonald's hamburger that had been in
there for at least two years he opened
it up expecting it to see like the mold
and the fur growing looked exactly the
same as the day boy fresh as a daisy and
I just gotta tell you I'm not eating
that okay if it can stay in a trench
coat for two years and not mold it
probably shouldn't go in my belly is all
I'm saying oh wow you know what I'm
saying you're right you're exactly right
and so but when it comes to nachos I'd
probably have to get some some processed
meat or something look I don't get me
started you know what I do with the tofu
I make it messing with you right I make
it work but that's what I'm saying hey
next time we're on together I want in
the third hour you to bring in some tofu
nachos I'll eat it on the air I want to
try it I'll do something I can't
guarantee it's gonna be nachos I'll do
something or tofu anything I've never
had tofu in my life what never all right
the only person I'll eat it for is you
but it has to be on the show I will hook
it up don't you worry about that Ken
Coleman all right well well that was fun
it was hey all that to say we get it as
Jade said she sees you she hears you and
we do so back to the phones we go it's
gonna be fun we're still here for you
don't move this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
all right folks welcome back to the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman and Jade
warshaw is with me and so in the last
segment I was talking about the uh
because because Jade's a clean eater
she's a cook uh she's she's fantastic
with food and she she makes me feel very
guilty and so I told the story about the
guy who discovered the burger and the
guys in the booth are so amazing they
looked it up so for those watching on
YouTube we're gonna pull this up on the
screen here I was wrong
ill in one major factor it wasn't two
years in the jacket it was 14 years Jade
gosh 14 years this McDonald burger and
now uh this article came out a couple
years ago so now the burger is by our
calculations 24 years of age oh no and
he's kept it Jade it's now a collector's
item if you would but it's still going
strong
I could nuke it and eat it oh I wouldn't
I wouldn't I said I could it's still in
its it look there's no mold on it
nothing it looks like you know I am
deeply there it is deeply Disturbed
there is the picture of that meat oh if
that's what you can call it
I have nothing left to go on after that
we're gonna leave that alone I all of a
sudden I have some indigestion so let's
move on all right uh
so a lot of you are thinking about
moving and that's always exciting
and we want to be excited for you we are
but
we also want to make sure that you know
what you're doing you're just going to
be facing some sky-high prices
interest rates aren't going to return to
the record lows anytime soon but that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't buy a
home and that it's going to be
impossible to buy a home if you want to
buy or sell you got to make sure you're
financially ready and you've got a
trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk you through it not a
family friend who just got their license
last month and not someone who does it
part-time who really wants to help you
out you need a pro a true expert and you
can find a high caliber Ramsay trusted
agent that through our endorsed local
providers program has been vetted
and their winners and have been winning
for a long time because they know what
they're doing and that now becomes
knowledge that helps you out and so we
vet these Agents from all around the
country you're going to get the best
support in your area whether you're
moving from Florida to Alaska uh or
you're buying your first home somewhere
in between
ramseysolutions.com
agent is the website to go to
agent and get yourself a real estate Pro
who we trust to help you out so there
you go also I'm supposed to mention no
I'm not that's next time we met some of
these uh real estate folks down in
Austin oh we did yeah in Indianapolis
yeah man and I can say these are great
people if you if you are not sure about
what we're talking about here these uh
Ramsay trusted real estate you need to
get on it and get about it because these
are real people they are vetted they
understand what's going on and uh yeah
just a little something there there it
is ramseysolutions.com agent all right
back to the phones we go Los Angeles
California is where Daniel awaits Daniel
how can we help
hey Cat hey Jade how are you sir
I am a university school I just moved
out here on campus I am four thousand
dollars in debt I have uh my baby step
one emergency fund I have another
thousand dollars in cash
um in my bank account and I currently am
not paying rent but uh my issue is
but I'm currently at a work study job
that is not paying me as much as I was
making with my prior higher education
experience and I wanted to see if
I should pivot that into either leaving
the you know that workplace
um or just adding something else onto
with the other experience that I have
but honestly the job that I'm currently
doing is in
um focus on the type of field that I'm
trying to continue it's administrative
it's not related it's not I'm sorry I'm
having a hard time understanding some of
what you're saying so I gotta clarify a
couple things
the current work study or the job you're
in now is not related to where you want
to be long term is that what I heard
it's related to higher education but not
related to teaching which is what I want
to do long term okay right so it's not
it's really not the latter that you want
to be on so that already is an indicator
that we want to get out of there I mean
it's stability to some level but not
much because you need to be making more
money but I want to pause the
conversation real quick I'm gonna come
and clean up something really fast uh
you've got four thousand dollars in debt
and you got four thousand dollars in
cash above and beyond baby step one
which is what we say is a one thousand
dollar amount in a savings account for
everyday emergencies real emergencies so
why wouldn't you take the four thousand
dollars cash above and beyond that go
ahead and pay that debt off and be debt
free that would immediately save you
money
correction it's a thousand dollars in
cash
um and I would like to put as much cash
down on the debt that I have yeah but my
my conflict is just a low pay at the
time okay so I heard you incorrectly
he's got he's got a thousand dollar
emergency fund he's got 4K in debt and
didn't you say you have an additional
thousand dollars
yes one and I have a thousand dollars in
my bank account at the moment okay I
thought I heard four I'm sorry okay we
see so we want you to get okay all right
never mind so we want you to keep
working the baby steps but I do have a
question regarding that money are you
gonna have student loans when you come
out of this
like are you are you paying cash for
college
so fortunately I have um financial aid
covers my work and my schooling
um at the moment I'm only paying 400 out
of pocket for uh you know the rest of my
rent and my parking permit good deal for
a quarter so that's about 1200 a year
okay good deal all right so let's just
focus on this professional question then
what's keeping you from stepping out of
this work you're doing now and getting
back into teaching
um honestly I've just been having a lot
of time conflicts with my transition to
the university and with housing but I
honestly need to just find another job
um there's a career fair today so I also
wanted to ask about some tips it is an
education as well so all right hit me
with it okay I mean we're here for you
how can I help you most right now
at the moment
um
I think I just need a little bit of a
nudge but I also need
um
I need guidance on how to transition or
if I should add or you can leave this
workplace in general no no I know that's
why we're kind of dancing around and
saying I'm saying what are you are you
doubtful are you fearful because we know
that I'm giving you the nudge I've
already told you that you need to start
looking and we're going to be leaving
this current job it is not the latter
that you want to be on we've already
established that
so what guidance do you need on the
transition because the transition in my
mind is very simple it is I'm looking
I'm connecting I'm interviewing I'm
accepting
that's it we don't leave the current job
until we have a new job to walk into so
transitions to me are really really
simple because we we remove risk there's
no risk involved in this scenario that
I've heard so far what are you earning
at this work study
clearly the max that I can that I can be
earning is about 310 a week take home
and so that's about so if you're
interested in education
and you're earning and you need to
replace 310 dollars a week can you just
start tutoring
is there anything else that you can do
on your own you don't need to wait for
anybody else you don't have to
do you see what I'm saying it's well I
believe I can see there I'm also looking
into different private companies that do
tutoring but on my own I just I don't
have any guidance for that and I know I
don't know where to start okay you do
know where to start
who do you want to teach
let's take all limits off who do you
want to teach what I do want to teach
higher education I want to teach are you
qualified to teach are you qualified to
teach at the higher education level
well if I teach but I do
tutor okay great so if you don't know
where to go it's called Google and when
you're in Los Angeles wherever you are
you're looking for people that are
tutoring it's called the proximity
principle it's a best-selling book I'm
going to give it to you because it's
going to actually take all of this fear
and all this confusion that you've got
in your head it's going to simplify it's
going to tell you the people to be
around the places to get into you just
need to get active my friend stop
thinking and start connecting when I
connect with the right people they help
me get in the right places and that's
when opportunity shows up knocks on my
door but young man I wrote an entire
book is going to walk you through it
hang on the line get your chin up
let's start going where the people are
that you want to help and you know where
to find them start looking hang on the
line
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me in studio
this hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're here to talk to you about
your life your money life your work life
your relationship life and we want to
help you win so we are here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day is Luke 21
19. stand firm and you will win in life
our quote from LeBron James people will
hate you rate you shake you and break
you but how strong you stand is what
makes you
say that or did he rip that off from
somebody that was like a book but like
he might be writing a song yeah I'd had
a little lyrical process okay I got to
bring this up and and I I think I know
where it's going to go and we can't we
can't spend more than 30 seconds okay
come on hit me
um
who's the greatest basketball player
Michael Jordan Michael Jordan and don't
at me thank you yeah I am willing to to
lose friends over this it's not even
close it's not even close and I love
bringing it up it's like the greatest
thing to fight about that never really
gets ugly because it's just that check
the Rings thank you check the Rings
that's all I'm saying thank you all
right all right hey after record high
prices and interest rates could the
housing market actually be cooling down
there have been some early indicators
but there's more to the story than just
a clickable headline we've got the full
scoop on the current housing market and
this weekend's edition of the Ramsey
newsletter simply sign up at
ramseysolutions.com newsletter that's
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter to subscribe to our Weekly
Newsletter all right back to the phones
we go Michael is in Indianapolis Indiana
Michael how can we help
hey uh just just to start off I'm glad
you both said Michael Jordan because I
might have had to hang up that's what
I'm talking about you're my guy I I
would have been okay with that good for
you sir all right how can we help
yeah so um my situation might be a
little different than uh some people
um right now but
um I've been working from home for seven
eight years
um so but I got them job opportunity
currently going through some
interviewing processes but they might
want me to come back into the office for
50 of the week so typically people are
worried about going to going to working
from home and uh I'm kind of thinking
about maybe moving back to the office
for 50 of the time but
um kind of just concerned about family
family time stuff like that right now
currently I'm a consultant so I've been
working in software Consulting I'm a
architect been working there for eight
years working from home and
kind of built a consulting company up to
sale and uh sold last year cashed out
and kind of don't see any real reason to
stick around don't really see too much
vertical movement here he's uh got an
opportunity with an insurance firm
possibly higher management so I'd be
reporting directly to the VP of the
company okay I'd be over pretty much
their software Solutions there and I'd
be over a team while they're developing
all the stuff that they're working on
well you get a nice bump as well and pay
not necessarily
um it sounds like I might get a little
bit but uh kind of not but the
opportunity for a nice bump is there
yeah yeah I think it might be a little
bit it might be like 10 15 000 but right
but I'm saying pretty well right but
over the course of the next several
years with growth that's where the
opportunity is coming is what I'm
hearing you say
yeah possibly possibly well it just kind
of depends on what their uh what their
pay increase schedule looks like okay
well I think you got to get you got to
find out that stuff you need to know
that's the kind of stuff it's okay to
ask you got to say you gotta ask them
what when somebody wants you it's okay
to be wanted but it's also okay for you
to say all right I got to see if I want
this and I'm asking what is my vertical
opportunity look like so I'd go find out
now here's the question I've got I think
this is the ultimate question
If this job that has been offered to you
was 100 remote
would you be calling me right now
no definitely not all right so that's
the answer
do you want this job
and I think you should take this job
but but when see when I remove the whole
remote thing it was like oh I'd
absolutely do it it's a good
professional move you're completely
worried
or
you're just really comfortable in this
remote gig you've been doing for seven
to eight years and so you've got to come
to grips with that my friend but I would
never ever ever ever ever ever
sacrifice an opportunity
because of comfortability your kids are
going to be fine your family's gonna be
fine if you go into work 50 of the week
am I right
oh yeah all right then for sure
so so here's my point
if the family's gonna be okay this now
comes down to your preference your
wife's preference and again that's an
okay thing but I but when you put it all
on the table and I hope you now and the
audience can see what I've just did I
just put everything on the table and I
would never turn down this opportunity
in this situation I would take it Jade
you're you're the the career coach but
this call relates to me deeply because
when you said what you that was my
situation before coming here built a
business is very successful and the I
was working I've all I've only worked
from home I've only worked um as a
contractor I've only worked for myself
so coming to Ramsey it was a big
opportunity a new opportunity totally
different I was gonna have to go into
the the workforce uh and come into the
office every day something I've never
done
um used to being able to be on my own
schedule if the kids need this I can go
do it and that was a big a big thing to
weigh
um so my two cents here is really making
sure that you're not doing it for or as
we went through the pay you're not doing
it but you truly truly love and feel
very connected to the purpose behind
what it is that you're going to be doing
because when when you start having those
doubts about oh man I used to be able to
just have this this level of autonomy or
I used you know it used to be I could
pick up the kids at any point and you're
used to that you'll immediately go back
to your why and it will be strong enough
to keep you do you know what I'm saying
oh yeah that's why I asked him would you
take this job
if it was remote and he said absolutely
and so we so there's more pulling at you
than a remote and so I'm assuming that
this is something that you're very
excited about and you see the potential
yes
oh yeah yeah I definitely see the
potential in it because it's like right
now I'm working Consulting it's like I
work I do the same thing I'd be doing at
this job yeah but I'd be doing it for
three four companies at once and there's
been multiple times where I've been on
two phone calls at once one one on each
year muting each one in between each
conversation because some of the
customers overlap meetings and the
customer is always right you know you
got to be in there and they don't care
if you have other projects because they
think they're your primary focus
yeah I mean you're excited about this
new challenge
right yeah I think so and I feel like it
would be less stress even though it
would be
um in the office because it's like I
work from home but I'm really locked in
my office from eight to five exactly
sometimes and here's the deal you said
this is hybrid this isn't even full time
this is hybrid I think it's a good thing
but I'd like to see you go from and
again Michael if you're using the word
think as just a throwaway word that's
fine but I'd like to hear you go oh yeah
I keep hearing I think so I think so so
I'm gonna challenge you
to go get to the answers that you need
to where you go I know so
right is this a good move for you
yeah yeah I think so I mean it would be
a good move for the career yes for sure
but again but again uh Jay she's she's
right and this is what I teach don't
just take this because you think so and
because it's we gotta know so
and here's the whole process I've been
I've been talking my life about it she
had a kind of an emotional response to
me not working from home anymore but uh
uh it's it's just like the initial hey
don't ignore that let me tell you
something my friend I will tell you that
everything you've told me so far says
that you should probably take this job
with the caveat that you go get more
answers so you know so but I'm going to
tell you something else you just threw
me new information mm-hmm
and this is a marriage decision make no
mistake about it well you better get
straight with her on this and it's not
as simple as her not being on board with
it it is it is your job and I'm going to
call men out here it is your job in this
situation because it's your opportunity
to go to your wife and cast a vision for
her and not tell her what you're doing
but sell it to her to where she actually
goes okay uh you better solve this
because if you take this gig and Jay
she's still having problems with it oh
it's going to be miserable so please get
this thing straight let's not rush into
this uh the weekend is a good time for
some dates some conversations here Mike
conversation hey great job Jade warshaw
always fun to be with you and I want to
say thanks to the Austin and the crew
there that kept us on the air today hey
America this is your show thank you so
much for being a part of it this is the
Ramsey Show
started on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]